chi di noi qui riconosce un momento
della sua vita in cui è la sensazione di
non avere un obiettivo o di non avere
gli obiettivi chiari chi prova questa
sensazione scomodo io mi sono posto
questa domanda
anche perché scomodo di non avere idee
chiare e mi sono sempre affascinato dal
fatto che noi umani vogliamo lineare i
tutti i processi che viviamo è la vita
sarà una festa semplice linea mentre noi
siamo organismi che viviamo anche le
stagioni quindi permettiamo anche a
volte l'autunno della nostra vita a
rientrare per rinfrescarci quando dovevo
scegliere il mio studio
non sapevo che cosa scegliere che io ho
scelto qualcosa per evitare di avere un
camino troppo stretto
poi l'aspettativa era di andare a
studiare poi lavorare mentre secondo me
un percorso di vita un po più giusto
potrebbe essere così che fai le cose
destra e sinistra e c'è una direzione
che forse dopo lo puoi capire è quando
le cose sembrano di diventare stabili
forse il tuo è un momento in cui la tua
vita viene stravolta è tempo di salutare
in un'altra fase di vita
io ho vissuto una fase senza obiettivo
in cui cercavo di comporre di nuovo un
idea di che cosa volevo questo è stato
dopo aver lasciato un lavoro in olanda
come manager dove lavoravo tanto alcuni
obiettivi gli obiettivi molti che hanno
tokai
ogni giorno ogni settimana dovevamo
vendere è stato un ambiente molto
interessante di che faceva che mi faceva
crescere per un certo momento non mi
potevo allineare con quegli obiettivi
che io ho deciso di andare in africa di
fare un viaggio da kate a nairobi per
ripensare che cosa sarebbe più azzeccato
per per me come persona e sono tornato
da un viaggio più radicato più atterrato
però avevo 30 anni non avevo soldi non
avevo una relazione una casa un
obiettivo è anche scomodo e non voglio
dare la colpa alla società
diciamo semplicemente sia la società
società che ci impone di avere sempre le
idee chiare e la storia chiara però è
soprattutto sei te stesso anche che ti
imponi per questa cosa allora di tele
veri che cosa sia questa queste coraggio
questo è ancora della mia immaginazione
come volevo
trasformare la mia vita in quel momento
quindi ho tagliato immagini e testi da
dalle riviste per comporre un collage
che mi ispirava e questo è un metodo che
si chiama veio burning viene anche
utilizzato da visionari di raccogliere
ogni angolo immagini che che possono
creare una visione
una visione che ti permette anche apre
creare una realtà da perseguire e
secondo me questo forse anche più forte
di un obiettivo quando qualcuno ti
chiede ma dovevo stare in cinque anni e
che cosa voi aveva fatto deve essere
molto concreto mentre la vita in un
viaggio e questo è stato un visual e che
ti ti guida in un punto in movimento
poco dopo aver fatto questi giorni mi
ero già iscritto in per un programma per
uno scambio per giochi imprenditori mi è
arrivato la richiesta di fare uno
scambio qui a matera che per me era un
punto sulla mappa che non conoscevo e
voglio chiede credere che proprio si
aprono le porte con inizia a visionare
una cosa e non a caso tornando a questo
già avevo intuito che mi avrebbero
chiamato della mattina
noi mattina però sembra allora potete
vedere che erano molto gioioso per
questo soloperto avevo invitato gli
amici per saltare nella grotta che
adesso anche gli amici materani lo
chiamano ruote di caspar perché facciamo
della politica e per me era una vera
scoperta un posto veramente
completamente non conosciuto con questa
bellezza e poi che ti viene che viene
fermato nella strada e ti chiedono ma
che fai qua e ci articola belle però
bevere era proprio non ha un'ispirazione
grande che cosa volevo fare io volevo
raccontare i posti e un modo diverso che
non far pubblicità a pensare come
dobbiamo fare marketing in questo posto
però vivere un posto attraverso il
viaggio spontaneo
avevo soltanto un merci da scambiare
non che le mie foto e video
non li voglio far vedere perché erano
veramente amatoriali però era un
bell'inizio e mi ha permesso di giocare
tanto perché potevo un tour operator mi
ha permesso di fare un viaggio in
sicilia è un altro albergo mi ha
ospitato per cinque giorni hanno fatto
delle foto
volevo mettermi in gioco solo dopo un
tempo si finiva vivono questi cinque
mesi che dovevo sperimentare però non
era diventato su chi sono perché con un
ciclo dei soldi ancora sia bisogno in
questo momento
avevo perso il treno da brindisi a bari
e poi li ho già stato scoperto che c'è
soltanto una navetta o la lumaca lucana
che quindi ero costretto di cercare un
albergo però avevo veramente pochi soldi
in tasca
elisa vuoi un punto di volare
[Musica]
però non ho fatto perché in questo
momento non avevo niente da perdere
era tutto o niente che mi sono buttato
in una nuova esperienza ho detto di sì a
un diverso mi piace credere anche di
questo si sa risultato in un progetto
che il progetto che avevo proposto qua
insieme con col mio è diventato un digit
onda ieri in basilicata che è diventato
un progetto molto interessante anche in
termini di martin territoriale in italia
i premi per me è stato proprio un sogno
perché invitavano anche degli artisti da
tutto il mondo per raccontare la
basilicata attraverso un viaggio e
c'erano dei ragazzi molto più bravi di
me e li ho messo un altro obiettivo
pongo vedevo queste queste linguaggio
non ho messo un altro obiettivo questo
obiettivo quindi sapevo che doveva
essere prendere tutto in serio dovevo
prendere fare una di quello che facciamo
e ho preso anche fascino di raccoglie
immagini hariri mixarli con musica suoni
un posto per colpire il viewer in pochi
minuti lasciare un emozione di un posto
questo sono tutti i friends in video che
ho fatto che abbiamo fatto in giordania
che è stato anche condiviso dal dalla
reggina è stato un grande onore
era quello il fascino
poi si è avviato proprio l'attività
prima in italia avevo chiamato da altri
enti pubblici e poi anche all'estero
aziende anche di compagnie aerei per per
avere un video che avevano già visto su
online che venire il progetto era
diventato più grande di me poteva
coinvolgere altre persone
[Musica]
quest'idea avevo già all'inizio si
chiamava story tra tolone essere però
ero da solo quindi in quel momento
poteva realizzare anche l'idea che aveva
già intuito all'inizio quindi abbiamo
formato un collettivo di
i filmaker di più o meno 15 posti
diversi nel mondo vedete il gruppo e poi
abbiamo potuto lavorare per più di 20 i
clienti in tutto il mondo
quindi matera era diventato capo mondo
in questo senso di questa attività
perché tornava sempre qua prende la
focaccia di san giacomo non potevo
vivere senza diverse poi guardando
questo pensavo ma posso anche raggiunto
questo obiettivo anche di più che
pensavo il billboard
forse è tempo di riposarmi di fare un po
di altre cose la sua coscienza forse ha
emesso qualcosa di nuovo all universo
che mi stavo forse per annoiare e poi
l'universo ha risposto perché stavo
lavando i piatti da casa dei geni
genitori e poi il tenere telefono la c'è
il numero di carta
rispondo signora arabo che dice abbiamo
visto il tuo video entro un mese
vogliamo fare un programma televisivo
per jasira back con
oltre 350 milioni di vivere in tutto il
mondo
quindi che ne pensi iniziamo quindi
chiuso il telefono è guardato i genitori
in negli occhi e mi corano è deciso e mi
sono buttato dentro e questo è stato una
nuova esperienza perché entro tre
settimane stava in albania
stavo in albania a gestire un dottore
arabo delle persone di che parlavano
albanesi dovevano avere istruzioni una
squadra nuova un ruolo nuovo per me e ho
preso un po di distanza di me stesso e
ho pensato questo ragazzo che deve fare
questo casino
sono io che ce la faccio
sono rientrato e me stesso e comunque
l'ho fatto e ho preso anche piacere
farlo è un risultato in quindici puntate
di mezz'ora in cinque paesi nel mondo
adesso avevo fatto per tutto questa
stagione per tv internazionale metering
ritrovo forse lo stesso cerchio in un
nuovo vuoto dove non so quale curva
verrà non è un problema non avere un
obiettivo perché forse tira anche spazio
a sufficienza spazio di prendere
l'obiettivo più importante nonché di
conoscere a te stesso e di vivere il tuo
viaggio con la vita tua come un viaggio
è così sempre tutto quello che in
progresso grazie provato insieme
[Applauso]